in this video we're going to be sharing
really some nuanced YouTube strategy
that's going to help you get more views
in 2023 if you're here on the replay I'm
here with my friend Dan from vid IQ
we're going to be doing some Channel
reviews some video reviews
um but the details we're going to be
discussing are worth watching this video
Until the End because uh we're gonna be
breaking down how you can better
position your YouTube channel to get
views and we're going to be speaking to
your individual videos or rather some of
the channels we'll be reviewing about
how you can hold audience retention
longer start your videos out better and
there'll be a lot more tips like that so
hit the like button if you're fired up
and we're going to dive into the first
channel in just a second but I want to
welcome Dan from bit IQ Dan how's it
going how was your Christmas it was
great it was great uh thank you for
having me and yeah I hope yours is
awesome I hope everybody here had a
great holiday season
yep uh yeah let us know if you're here
live how your holiday season was and uh
let's dive straight into this I'm
pulling um channels off of our video
ranking Academy Group which is our kind
of YouTube uh group coaching program and
then also off of Twitter you should be
able to see a pinned comment or we will
repin it and uh the queue of channels is
probably already full but uh definitely
share your channel if you want to do
that and we're kicking it off with
Marsha Vogel and as we
um land on the channel here I love it
because
um immediately I knew it was about
essential oils just from the thumbnails
of the shorts you can't actually upload
thumbnails on shorts but uh just those
starting screenshots or whatnot and then
she says array of Hope Essentials a
little more
kind of inspirational type of title
that's somewhat veiled we do like to
coach Clarity is better than being
clever but the combination of essential
oils here and Essentials in the title
kind of helped me make that connection
and it's cool to see that I think okay
we do have videos and we do have shorts
and it seems to be that shorts were the
prominent feature as a reminder
um
one of the things to do as you get ready
for 2023 is clean up your home page
um and clean up the home page of your
channel it seems that she chose her
shorts shelf or her shorts playlist to
be the first thing then it's videos
great and uh let's um one of the things
we're also going to be doing today is
some video reviews and so her most
recent uploads seven days ago there
shorts is very hard to see so we don't
know when these came out
uh
[Music]
probably get capture written strict
stricken 48 times in this video but
that's great let's check out this video
today we're going to make a delicious
white chocolate peppermint flavored
popcorn that is delicious and it makes a
great gift too
really good uh looks like also it's sort
of like starting with the final
uh result here you have the popcorn
that's great and uh you've got
um uh and then you cut back and it's a
really good hook so a way to get
straight to the point not waste any time
right at the beginning and then get into
the recipe
um you know a couple thoughts here is
that
um you know people have different
preferences people love authenticity uh
but but I do notice that there's just
stuff in the shot that's distracting
um the it the the uh cloth over here the
towel over here maybe for cleaning the
countertops uh some of the stuff over
here and then even the sign of our
kitchen the framing of the shot I think
that the visual Aesthetics of a shot we
always say start before you're ready
punch here in the face press record but
you do want to get one percent better
with every upload so the the camera is a
little low in shooting up at you it's
also kind of off kilter it's super
oriented to the right showing the our
kitchen and sign and so there's plenty
of things to distract me in the shot
typically if your your goal is to have
the camera a little bit at eye contact
at eye level or at eye level or slightly
above and pointed down becomes a more
flattering shot as well so one of the
things to do potentially is to invest in
maybe a tripod uh this season if you
don't have one that can go tall enough
so sometimes they're too short so you
look at one that's maybe 60 70 75 inches
80 inches as far as how high it can go
and uh just be thoughtful of your shot
composition just one way to improve the
video
um and and then I'm also noticing the
audio here and not too bad you can
definitely hear you but it seems like
we're going to take on camera audio it
sounds better once you get behind the
camera because I'm sure you're closer to
the microphone so just other little
things like knowing that a lav mic if
you have a mic input and whatever camera
or into your phone you know it's like a
12 to 19 investment that could help the
um audio as well I love that you've got
multiple b-roll things uh happening here
and it looks like you've embedded closed
captions or rather you've just dress it
up yeah embed it embedding closed
captions is pretty cool because this is
not YouTube's closed caption so that's a
good way to deliver that information and
and uh and and help the viewer there's a
lot of data that shows us that closed
captions are are really great and one of
the things we finally say before any of
Dan's thoughts on the channel is UM
success leaves Clues make part twos
and so at think media here we teach
you know answer specific questions and
then we also teach
okay
ask this question when you're creating
your next video what is my audience's
biggest problems and pains
and what are their biggest Ambitions
what's interesting to me is your most
viewed video only two months ago and
it's still getting 13 views per hour and
what's cool is with vid IQ installed we
can see this these um extra data points
with trending and stats we can see that
it's still getting 13 views per hour the
vph the velocity
it's two months old
but it's actually about pain like it was
I don't mean actually to be that meta
that like their pains but think when
people have pains in this case muscle
cramps they really want to solve those
pains so how to easily and naturally
stop muscle playing and sleep better
that is what my desires to sleep better
I want to relieve pain it ties exactly
into what you're doing I found yourself
just I think that a really good hook
again here
amazing Marcia you're casting the vision
I have found myself and I'm not sleeping
good now I need your help Marcia tell me
what I need to do
your cat so good and so uh then we've
got all that happening one other thought
is I would assume you're you're a
um distributor of Doterra which is a
network marketing company my wife and I
actually love Doterra I love the breathe
I got to get some from my office here
and
um and uh and if possible I'd be
thoughtful about thinking what do you
want to happen can I order exactly what
you're teaching on here easily and I
have to dig pretty deep in your
description to find it I eventually find
your diffuser down here
um and so now I would imagine Yep this
is your your store so I could go a
little deeper but even this so this
point would be
we like to say like what is the viewer
Journey or what is even like the
customer Journey if someone wanted to do
business with you whether that's an
affiliate product or something when I
land on here it says whoops your link is
expired so that sort of breaks the chain
while you're here shop the system well
now I'm confused discovered Otero I
don't want to just go on a New Journey I
want the exact thing that you're leading
me to the roller bar ball press is here
so that's nice but when I get okay I get
here great so if you talk about that in
the video so all that to say is like we
like to think about maybe having a link
above the fold and making it as easy as
possible for whatever it is you're
sharing about to help people whether
it's a product through your company
whether it's an affiliate product
whether it's your own thing you've
created whether it's a link to another
video I I just like to have a clickable
link in the top three lines not just to
fill it with something random to
actually fill it with something
intentional that you communicate in the
video but Dan is there anything uh
you're noticing here on Marsha's Channel
so in the popcorn video I was I was
looking around and I noticed by the way
really strong content I just think that
the focus here is really really good uh
there's a there's a lot of things going
on that are right I thought the title
was a bit long and I you'll notice a
really big difference in the title of
that really popular video you just
pulled up in this one so how to make
white chocolate peppermint
um I think it was peppermint popcorn and
then at the end of it it said a simple
snack that anyone can enjoy and I think
you basically have two titles there and
you could have combined them really well
kind of like you do this how to easily
and naturally stop muscle cramps to
sleep better like you're you're saying
you have an easy natural solution to a
problem and with the popcorn thing I
think it's kind of similar you have a
simple way to make a delicious treat
and I I think you ended up with like two
titles in the end so I would always be
kind of thinking about the part of the
title that's gonna get truncated you
want to try to avoid that at all costs
but uh if you have to have a long title
what's the most important bit what's the
pit what's the bit that if someone stops
scrolling because of your thumbnail they
read the title and they're like oh
simple white chocolate Pop yeah I want
to know how to do it and it sounds
pretty easy so I'm gonna check it out
but the the part that made it sound easy
was kind of hidden so and that's just a
nitpick for an otherwise really really
strong Channel
yeah and um one kind of cool thing I
mean today's video is brought to you by
vidiq and if you want to uh check out
vid IQ you could do a 30-day trial of uh
one of the paid plans for just a dollar
at vidiq.com forward slash think one of
my favorite Tools in here
um is the uh
AI title recommendations and just for
fun let's type in how to make white
chocolate peppermint popcorn which is
the beginning of your title and now
check out the AI title recommendations
here how to make white chocolate
peppermint popcorn the easy way so how
to really clear a little bit of energy
the exclamation all right how to make
white chocolate peppermint popcorn
simple
um without a stove or an oven this also
what's kind of cool about this is these
aren't just title ideas they actually if
you do this ahead of time these are
video ideas because
um if you want to stand out and get
views in 2023
and you're thinking it's too crowded the
the riches are in the niches they say in
online business and it's okay how to
make
something what is the desire but also
then with with limitations so I remember
back in the day I did a baked salmon
video and I was experimenting with all
kinds of videos how to bake salmon in an
oven with a tin foil boat that's where
we're talking about like distinctions
you'd call them long tail keywords and
so maybe there's a lot of competition
around just making the popcorn but you
very specifically we say answer specific
questions the specific word means like
not just make the stuff but without a
stove or an oven or over a fire you know
or or with limited
um you know resources and so um the
perfect winter treat this is like I love
this tool because it's kind of giving
you
that search-based intense based speak to
YouTube speak exactly to the desire but
also put some kind of energy on there
and uh then you can also just generate
new ideas and go pretty deep down the
rabbit hole the perfect Christmas gift
like different ways uh that you can find
so that's one cool tool in there and
with that we're going to jump over next
to Twitter where
um some channels have been submitted and
we're gonna go with Gone to the Snow
Dogs here in just an order of how the
tweets are showing up for me now I Love
Gone to the Snow Dogs back in the
clubhouse days we would be hanging out
all the time uh in clubhouse rooms
during the pandemic and so it's a really
cool Channel and
um I think I if I recall that there was
also a short Channel separate so we have
seven uploads 1.7 million views and uh
on channel Snow Dogs
uh there's a hundred thousand
subscribers here I don't know if this is
just shorts five months ago there lots
of shorts over here so I remember back
in shorts people were like should you
split the channel should you all keep it
on one channel Dan what do you think
before we get into the channel the
question of should you separate shorts
and longs
in 2023 what's your thoughts if you're
starting now no uh if if the content in
my opinion if the content is similar to
the audience you're already catering to
with your long form content or vice
versa you should take advantage of the
fact that YouTube's basically given us
three channels in one we have long
videos we have live streams and we have
shorts so starting now yes the channel
we just looked at already had a shorts
Channel with a hundred thousand
subscribers and so in that sense I
wouldn't necessarily change anything
because that's that's awesome like it
looks like they are uploading some
shorts to it now but I I think having
another channel that got you a silver
play button is is a badge of honor and
that's great and you probably built up
an audience over there but uh there's
nothing wrong with it I just think if
you're trying to grow one channel if you
have a desire to get a bunch of
subscribers and Views and you're trying
to build up an audience organically you
can definitely use shorts now to do that
it was not the case back in the day
though Sean if you remember like there
was kind of a disconnect there between
shorts and long form videos and and
YouTube is admitted now that hey there
was was a disconnect we have now made a
connection and we want you to post
everything on one channel because it's
going to start recommending your
long-form videos to your shorts viewers
yeah and they're putting in the work
because you've got the Snow Dogs shorts
with gun with the Snow Dogs the brand
and they did just upload on December
28th yesterday okay you've also got the
Vlog Channel 351
000 subscribers
you've also got snow dogs cooking and
you've also got Gone to the Snow Dogs
this is a media this is a snow dog
Empire yes uh and so
um what what I think is interesting
about that strategically for everybody
watching though is that if you're
pumping out content especially like in
Vlogs the opportunity
especially around your what topic what
Niche you have something animals that is
incredible snow dogs it's a whole
separate passion cute moments that are
happening you're also capturing
constantly so if you're not in a vlog
lifestyle you're not really capturing
random stuff constantly but they are
so you could be editing your Vlog and be
like that could be a short you could be
editing you know one of your main videos
or whatever and and so I think that this
is kind of a unique case study to learn
from
um from an all all in perspective of how
you can DJ your content out on multiple
platforms but let's try to find our way
back to the main Channel a million
subscribers out here
and we've got uh about 1.7 million views
a month I'm curious why subscriber I
know that this doesn't always
necessarily load properly but I wonder
why it's uh not not growing there this
is one of my favorite tabs with uh vid
IQ that it adds to your
anybody's channel so you could of course
see this kind of information behind the
back end of your YouTube channel but you
essentially could like spy on your
competitors by seeing which videos have
velocity and this would be one thing I
say to you I know that
um Jess you know your Channel's
entertainment based
um you're pumping out content so many
people are subscribed for the story and
for the journey but if there's a moment
you lean in think media podcast
Community this is the moment I know
there's different YouTube philosophies
but this trending page in your analytics
it would be your real-time views
is the game of I believe avoiding
burnout
having a channel that lasts building a
real sustainable business on YouTube
really actually cracking the code of
YouTube I get it you can constantly
Chase virality but there is something so
powerful
about views on your older videos 24 7
365. so to illustrate
um what I'm seeing on the trending page
here is this is a million subscriber
Channel
but there's not a lot of videos here 12
days ago this video is still getting
clicked on probably by subscribers and
browse features three days ago these are
new videos but the two videos that are
super interesting to me is this video
seven months old and it still gets 40
views an hour the reason I love this is
when I look at this channel this is just
my perspective I'm curious who Dan will
share in a second this seems like a lot
of work which is fine I'm we're not
afraid of work but just a lot of videos
a lot of things to upload
but if I if you create a video seven
months ago and it gets you 40 views per
hour today then you can take a week off
during Christmas and still have your
channel be growing oh yeah um this one's
two months old and it's still getting
views so
if we flip it and and really the think
media methodology
is we create intent based or
search-based content and what I would
ask you to consider is that this doesn't
it's not either or like you can create
search based videos that continue to be
recommended and suggested for years if
you just do it intentionally and it
won't be off brand you can still Vlog
you can still do all this stuff it's
just a way of thinking so by comparison
if we go to think media's trending page
here using this tool this is how many
videos we have
that and by the way it goes much deeper
than this because the lowest amount of
views per hour on this page is 26. so
imagine just getting one view per hour
that's 24 views a day imagine getting a
half of you an hour that's 12 views a
day even if you posted the video a year
ago and so yes this was posted eight
days ago so it's still getting
recommended browse features but we got
two months a year two years we've got
nine months old we've got two years old
so maybe one of the biggest thoughts
because you're obviously able to create
content you have really great thumbnails
you're you got a million subscribers
you're you're you got a gold play button
I mean you're you're killing it you're
killing the game but what I would when I
look at your monthly views and it's 1.7
million also respect uh total but it's
like it just the the amount of hustle
you have to continue to put in
um I would just be thoughtful of how can
I create videos today that give me
leverage so that my channel grows
whether I post new content or not and so
looking at some of these metrics I think
is kind of important on the back end
because it looks like you know right now
we're about 4.5 million views a month on
on think media and it's not because like
our new videos are necessarily getting
massive views and a lot of people get
tricked by this they're like why aren't
your videos getting views you're like
well
you know there's different ways to
approach it and you're like you might
only see 24 000 views today on that six
day old video but the thing is in two
and a half years from now that video
will still be getting 24 views a day and
we keep posting videos so the entire
Channel just multiplies and grows so if
you could kind of get it some of that
thinking in your 2023 strategy I think
you could create a lot more as our
friend Sunny leonarduzzi says views
while you snooze and uh that's kind of
the dream Dan what do you think about
the channel
I love this Channel and I think a
Direction they can go in if they're
looking to implement that strategy would
be to take a look at these more popular
videos and I noticed one big difference
and the one that you said was getting 40
views an hour still even though it was
seven months old and that was that in
that video they were teaching their dog
how to swim
and I'm not a dog owner but I have to
imagine that dog owners in general this
is probably something they're interested
in and I think there's probably some
value in this video for people who have
Huskies or other dog breeds who would
like to teach them how to swim whereas
some of the more recent videos and I
think you should do both some of the
recent videos are you just kind of
enjoying time with your pets you know
opening presents things like that so to
me there's like a clear difference this
is the more search driven kind of
strategy here and I think it's catering
to a much wider audience and then the
other videos are more for your your
close-knit community people who are just
fans of you fans of your pets
um you know dog owners themselves and
there's kind of enjoying life with you
uh there's Merit to both styles of
content but I think the these types of
videos where you're teaching your dogs
how to swim this appeals to a lot of
people this opens up the door really
wide to not even just husky owners like
just dog owners in general
I would also say again talking about
learning points and for our entire
Community here it is cool that you got a
pinned comment
linking to a kit dot Co which is a place
where you can aggregate
affiliate links
with pool and swimming fun stuff for
dogs so the strategy is thinking okay
how do I create you know a video that
adds value related to my Niche my
passion my dogs my family
this definitely has evergreen properties
to it clearly because it continues to
give views and even the newest comment
was two months ago and the video is
seven months old so you could see it
continues to have new people engaging
with it but just I think a lot of people
Miss on the miss out on the opportunity
of using the pinned comment and most
people either don't do it at all or
don't do it strategically and so uh but
with that I mean again like we're here
to hopefully just add a little bit of
value you're absolutely smashing and uh
you should be incredibly proud of uh
everything that you're doing I also not
only are you seeing the pin comment
another thing people miss out on is
using their Community tab it looks like
you're doing Daily Posts on the
community tab with a variety of posts
great Square image here Carousel
actually very cute
um that's awesome and then also having a
poll here just the merry Christmas shout
out I think you're using it right
because also I don't think there's it's
necessary to
um uh you know be constantly pushing
like calls to action it's not bad this
would be the way to do it upload a
square image and then have a YouTube
link like this that's the best way to
share a video
um so that is for sure best practice but
but remembering that the community tab
is this chance to make a more emotional
more personal connection with your
audience and and now the community tabs
basically open up to everybody I mean
I've heard Channels with 23 subscribers
you got to do a couple things to back in
and then you can kind of get it so
there's a tip for 2023 start using your
community tab
um and then Dan I don't know if it's
necessary to use hashtags here and also
the problem with hashtags in my opinion
they can look kind of messy and they
actually can then they can lose their
functionality because the real key is
you're like okay so what's even the
point of that is it going to get more
reach on the post I don't think it is
but it's clickable so then you go okay
I'm on go to the snow dags there's snow
dogs if I click Merry Christmas am I
going to stay on go to the Snow Dogs and
actually go deeper on your channel
apparently not I'm gonna actually get
distracted by Mariah Carey and now I'm
singing the top Christmas songs
so clickable hashtags can be dangerous
unless you're using a clickable hashtag
that actually potentially builds your
brand and what do you think about this
you know I would love to talk to YouTube
about hashtags and and learn where
they're going with them because I've
also noticed something else if you
upload a short from your phone by the
way earlier you mentioned picking
thumbnails for your shorts this is
another thing that you can do if you
upload a short from your phone you can
freeze frame a thumbnail now this is
like a new feature and I was playing
with this tool over the weekend and I
also noticed that they were suggesting
hashtags for me to put in my title like
just like Instagram does just some
hashtags I can click on and add to my
title and I'm because I'm starting to
notice people are using hashtags in
their titles of shorts not just hashtag
shorts like all kinds of stuff and I'm
telling people don't do that and then
YouTube is like encouraging it so I
don't know what exactly that means but I
agree with you in the sense that right
now hashtag functionality makes zero
sense in terms of growth because if you
click on those like we just saw you come
to a page and it's the top videos that
have used that hashtag and not your
content so what I've always done is I've
made hashtags that are very very
specific to my channel and I have those
kind of automatically in every video
so hopefully if someone clicks on it now
they're introduced with a library of my
videos and if someone else has jumped on
the hashtag they're probably not going
to be able to compete with the sheer
amount of content that I've used that
hashtag with in the past and that's how
I've always used them on YouTube they
make a lot of sense to me on places like
Instagram they don't make any sense on
YouTube but I I have a just a curiosity
is that changing in 2023 based on
YouTube kind of pushing us like hey you
should use these in your short titles
I'm like why tell us more YouTube so I
don't know I'm more boundaries that's a
really good prediction to prepare for is
you know subscribe if you're not
subscribed here on um the think media
podcast Channel because things are
always changing and and I I would agree
with that like I did a video yesterday
on a reacting to a Fast Company article
my three hashtags because they are
clickable right next to
they move them they're no longer above
the title which is probably a little bit
better for not distracting the viewer uh
they they're you have your views you
have your uh upload date and then you've
got any hashtags in the description that
become clickable I use Sean Cannell
makes sense and kind of a rare name I
use think media podcast and then think
media and the key is to go test it so if
you click on your hashtag like Dan does
the same thing chances are other people
could could try to use the think media
podcast hashtag but it's it's it's
dominated what would even be the point
it wouldn't be their brand and so the
goal currently I would say the goal of
hashtags is more of like a way to
aggregate your content so people could
click that and then find other cool
stuff that they might be interested from
your world and uh here's uh some shorts
maybe a few other non-think media people
through think media podcast as a as a
#but you can see we also have those and
that's another one that's one thing we
want to do on this channel in 2023 start
uploading more shorts here a couple a
week is the goal um all right we're
going to get into another channel in
just a second if you have a question uh
generally about YouTube put four
question marks before and after the
question hit like if you've been getting
value in this video
um Dan's got a channel he's going to be
leading off with he also has a real
expertise in gaming but today's video is
also brought to you by vid IQ if you
haven't picked up your 30-day trial of
vid iq's paid plan yet just a dollar for
30 days vidiq.com forward slash think we
just were talking about the
um daily uh ideas tool
um there's another cool tool which is
the AI description tool you may have
been seeing things like chat GPT in fact
a little bit later Dan's gonna be
showing us a new tool that that vid IQ
has that is like an AI coach that will
help you
um you know understand YouTube better
but yesterday as I was putting out this
Trends video
I kept the description pretty simple and
had a link to a free class that we're
doing that's on replay right now I threw
a link to the article I was referencing
I did my time codes I threw my podcasts
in there I repeated think video podcast
and I should have just done think media
and then this is actually some copy some
text that vidiq description tool spun up
for me so I just clicked the button and
in this video we'll give you a rundown
of the top four Trends to watch for in
the crater economy in 2023. what's the
point here this is some like search
based text based as the internet
continues to evolve the Critter economy
is going to become increasingly
important so by by quickly just
reinforcing my video with text
um in this video we're going to share
the top four Trends with you and so
anyways just a really cool tool that you
can check out you can get a 30-day trial
of of uh vid IQ with some of of those
tips and I'll show you it in here too
now now that's in here I'm logged in our
other channel but see it says AI
description generator it wants some
keywords
uh this Wu tank Clan this is short
coming out one lesson I learned from the
Wu-Tang Clan let's see what it does with
this and so you can throw your title in
there in this video we take a look at
one YouTube lesson learn from the
Wu-Tang Clan this lesson is on the
importance of creating a strong YouTube
presence and cultivating a dedicated fan
base and so you could just insert it or
copy it and paste it wherever you want
in the description that's going to be
give you a marginal increase of course
your click-through rate your average
view duration but what shocks me is you
know Michael Jordan said Master the
fundamentals and everything else you do
will rise if YouTube gives me tags to
put in there I want to use that right if
YouTube gives me a description I want to
use that right if hat if they give me
hashtags I want to use those right I
want my title to be the best it could be
I want of course my thumbnail and all
those details to be the best they could
be and what's cool is that with AI this
takes one second so if all things
created equal are you don't do this and
I do this well my once it gives me that
advantage that I can literally do 2 in
one second and so AI is a cool
discussion in general because there's so
much wild stuff happening with it but
I'd love to see that vid IQ is uh
including those AI types of things
um that have been happening and so
uh with that Dan let's hit a question
how important is it for you to establish
to establish you as a person when
starting a channel if your channel is
around finances so I think Alan's saying
how important is it to
build Authority or to have a personal
brand if you're talking about finances
Dan any thoughts
so
how important is to establish you as a
person when starting a channel sorry
okay you were talking about AI stuff and
I started experimenting the background
yeah I'll smash it I'll come back to you
I would say that uh
it one of the important things Alan and
everybody watching on YouTube depending
on the niche but really for almost every
Niche especially if you're an educator
so let's speak to education because in
entertainment it's either is the video
funny they're not asking too many
questions about you you just grab their
attention right at the beginning I would
say it's pretty important Alan to
establish Authority now you're also not
trying to fake it till you make it
you're not trying to lie but if you're
about to share with finances in some
cases you know I think about like my
friend Andre dick he actually is pretty
bold to say listen this is not Financial
advice I love to research uh he even
kind of jokes he's like I'm actually
kind of like an idiot and and I'm here
to present the news to you
um and so he he wants to be thoughtful
and by the way he's grown a massive
Channel because he's consolidating he's
curating and he is taking action and
he's sharing his mistakes
another channel uh one of our recent
video raking Academy students Larry
Chung he's a chartered financial analyst
and so I think that's kind of some
important information to know because he
also then has a newsletter about
finances so I think it's a
self-awareness thing
but I also think that establishing your
Authority is a big deal because people
are asking the question why can I trust
you or why should I trust you
now a problem that people have with this
is they sometimes think it comes off as
bragging but it's not bragging it's
branding and it is if if
relationships move at the speed of trust
for you to have a relationship with the
viewer giving them a few signals and
signs that they can trust you is a
powerful thing to do
so a little formula we like to use or or
a framework is you also you don't want
to take 10 years doing this that'll bore
people to death but some things you can
insert here is how much experience do
you have so you like I've been working
at a bank I've been working at a Stock
Investing firm I've been studying and
researching financial markets for five
years so the amount of time you've done
something can be an authority piece this
is why it could be powerful to write a
book so if I say you know hey Sean
Cannell here
um best-selling author of the book
YouTube Secrets I think it's the number
one best-selling YouTube strategy book
in the world with like eight over 80 000
copies sold and in this video I want to
get into you know that's it's kind of
like ah you kind of bragging about you
but but it's also like well listen I
wrote a book you know like and and it's
also done incredibly well so do you have
you know hey and then maybe titles would
be another one so have you created
something you might even say you know
hey Sean Cannell here creator of the
video ranking Academy author of YouTube
secrets and founder of think media so
those things also might not mean much to
someone but in one sentence you're like
okay you actually have done a few things
and so this is not suggesting that for
you to start creating YouTube content
that you have to be an expert or have a
long list of letters after your name but
it is asking how can you be thoughtful
especially if you're going to be
teaching or talking about finances to
build as much trust and Authority with
the viewer as possible and so those are
a few thoughts of uh what I would do
there Dan can you pull up uh or I'll
pull up your channel that you linked for
me and uh we'll jump to yours in a
second if you're getting value smash
the like button it is a happy New Year
here at uh think media and uh Dan has
pulled up a channel called Brown coat
um let me get the link because I'm on
the wrong
browser Microsoft Edge forces itself on
me whenever I open links from slack and
so uh here we are we are on a Minecraft
Channel
um
and uh we're on the proper browser Dan
take it away
yeah so Brown coat uh I did see this
channel from Twitter and I thought okay
let's see what we got and I was very
impressed with the sheer amount of
subscribers and the videos they made the
the dedication to uh to this game is
very very popular and one that a lot of
people fear is too saturated right oh
Minecraft is is way too how am I
supposed to grow a channel
um well uh this person is doing just
that and as you can see here in the
popular tab they got a lot of awesome
success uh with command blocks
specifically they seem to be all in on
this item for those who don't know it's
a block in the game that you can add in
and you can code it to kind of do all
sorts of crazy things so there's a lot
of different tutorials and different
opportunities this channel has to take
this very complex item and show people
just what it's capable of and so in this
video we're looking at now which was
very popular
they how to get super powers in
Minecraft with command blocks like dead
simple title uh really like on the
surface a simple concept for a very
complex thing that they're going to
teach so videos like this can bring a
lot of value to people so if you have an
expertise in the game you're playing you
can see how that can translate now what
they're doing lately is still with
command blocks but something is not
working for them as well as it did back
then and I was kind of thinking about
this before we went live
and what I want to say about this is
like for example Harry Potter spells
learn to master eight Harry Potter
spells in Minecraft
now what is the difference between that
title and the video we've just saw with
over 100 000 views and the difference is
the focus is no longer command blocks
despite them being in the thumbnail you
made the focus of the title of this
video mastering Harry Potter spells
which everyone knows are not actually in
the game
so you kind of got away from showing me
something that is going to register my
brain is like oh I can add Harry Potter
spells to Minecraft instead you made it
look like you're playing a totally
different game or maybe a modded version
of Minecraft so you've just kind of
narrowed your audience in my opinion a
bit much there so I would have just
reframed that video adding Harry Potter
spells to Minecraft and I kind of wonder
if that would have changed things for
you but then the other thing I wanted to
point out about this journey you're on
with command blocks is that the more
specific you get with adding four
superpowers and this that and the other
um the farther away you get from the new
player the person who just got Minecraft
for the first time and they're barely
even learning what command blocks are I
think you should do both I think you
should be catering to these really
interesting trending topics if there's a
new Thor movie coming out then yes if
you know how to add Thor Powers using
command blocks do with the Thor video
but also keep in mind that you can do a
whole series on the basics of command
blocks you could do a whole series where
command blocks are solving problems for
players that they're having in the game
and I know as a Minecraft player myself
I know you have to like spawn them in
you have to kind of cheat to put them in
the game but
um once they're there you they're very
complicated it's just a text window like
there's so much you can teach people
with this thing because it literally
just opens up a text when you're like
what do I do with this
and the instructions have never been
super clear in my opinion so if you have
this expertise which clearly you do I
would be trying that two-prong strategy
of get the new people who are playing
this game for the first time uh with
those really early videos you know early
in terms of their experience with
command blocks and then get those super
fans who are really into like what is
basically mods that you're adding into
Minecraft without actually modding the
game really impressive and then the last
point I wanted to make before throwing
it back to you Sean was that some of
their thumbnails on these more popular
videos are very vibrant very colorful
very appealing while some of the
thumbnails they've done on more recent
videos are missing something they they
they're lacking a certain level of
Polish they're not standing out as much
they're using like dark backgrounds and
that was something that kind of stood
out to me as well you have kind of
characters wearing dark robes on a on a
dark background you have sometimes
you're just using straight black
background with some text you're kind of
letting the text be the hero of the
thumbnail uh so be thinking about that
too like look at the Minecraft videos
that are standing out today and compare
your thumbnails to theirs and you'll
notice right away the level of work
they're putting into making sure these
thumbnails are colorful and vibrant and
look at these ones we're getting 3 000
views on these videos and just the ones
at the top of the screen there with
fantastic vibrant thumbnails
so just just a few things I noticed
while digging through this channel
and just uh
a thought too is that YouTube recently
rolled out the channel update and the
app update dark mode is Now the default
so of course people can override and go
back into light mode but this black
background on dark mode would you'd see
these items but it wouldn't have a key
word in making your thumbnails clickable
and stand out contrast so just a thought
again that's how many of the viewers are
going to have dark mode versus light
mode well by default it's going to be
more dark because most people will
probably never change it once they
update their app that'll be true so it's
a very tactical Nuance to be aware of in
a new year
um and yeah other than that really great
advice to uh our resident gaming expert
uh Dan the other thing that I love to
point out here is this is actually my
advice to gaming channels probably what
I see the most and I think Dan sees it a
lot too is that a lot of people are like
I want to start a gaming channel and I
want to get famous and I'm just doing
random playthroughs the thumbnails are
kind of mediocre the titles are maybe
kind of mediocre part one part two part
three and they upload 40 of a 40 hour
game they upload 40 play throughs and
everyone's trying to do that because
what a dream to be able to just do play
throughs and get views it's not
suggesting that that can't work
but if you put in a little bit more work
and actually do
value-based content this is actually
what we would summarize as TSS teach
specific skills or answer specific
questions because people say how do I
use custom NPCs in Minecraft and
to the My overall perception of the
channel as well is that when we just
look at the stats like you're crushing
154 000 views up four percent
subscribers are up and so on a macro
it's always looking at the channel yes
definitely some incredible tips from Dan
of some of these past bangers and how
could we create those and then one other
thing to Echo to just kind of uh put it
in language we like to use not only do
we say success makes you know success
leaves Clues make part twos
but it just came to me now that another
thing we'd love to to say is Success
leaves Clues make part twos
and then turn it into a series of part
threes and fours so I I didn't know
about command blocks but you you just
unlocked a nugget there that if you take
okay you really understand the viewer
the Creator understands the viewer best
wins you understand their desires that
they want command blocks and maybe steer
away from trying to go super trendy with
tying it into Harry Potter and this
could be a 5 10 15 20 part series over
the next couple months you do all 20 of
those parts your playlist strategy is
dialed the videos are dialed you put all
the research and all the work into the
videos and you build them up you've
built this probably unbreakable series
that might lift the Bedrock of your
channel to 500 000 views a month have
those videos bring in a lot of new
people and then as you do other types of
topics and whatnot your subscribers are
growing your views are growing the key
takeaway there would be the series
strategy don't ask what video should I
make next ask what series should I make
next
next channel so we're looking at learn
with Rome learn Romanian with Karina
um one basic thing that I noticed right
off the bat I would I see that you've
got
underscores in your handle that's also
not my favorite
um but that's fine I would delete the
underscores out of your YouTube channel
name
um little thing it's probably not going
to make your channel grow or not but it
just sort of looks just strange in my
opinion and it would just kind of be
cleaner more professional to have uh
just delete those easy to do doesn't
really change much secondly you do have
the opportunity to um
upload a channel cover and it just is
not here so we're not seeing it so just
thinking about
you know for all of us ask yourself
think media podcast community
when was the last time you did a winter
cleanup of your YouTube channel what do
I mean cover Avatar about page
nothing there links links that overlap
to your social media accounts or to to
an email list or something else
playlists
with great optimized titles
which are on the home page of your
YouTube channel I mean some of uh we
were just talking about this with Kyle
and Nolan and Kyle are now kind of
directing think media
um on the think media team and um
and the home page Channel trailer
for unsubscribed viewers
return main video for subscribe viewers
which by the way the difference there is
you can do a channel trailer and then a
featured video for returning subscribers
this is in your channel customization
and then your feature selection so your
home page is do you want videos do you
link to another channel do you have a
short shelf and then thinking how am I
categorizing the videos on my channel so
like we have a series on camera dummies
cameras for dummies we have a lighting
series we even have playlists that are
optimized like this called camera
tutorials and best tips and tricks the
zve E10 all in one playlist Canon M50
all in one playlist Sony zv1 all-in-one
playlist so I share all that too because
obviously again we're much further along
but I like to think about okay on your
home page just a few things you could do
you probably make a lot of progress and
just set a block in your calendar for an
hour to just kind of clean up your
channel and and
um and think about not just created
playlists but potentially having to
different featured sections and then
probably the biggest takeaway of all of
that is it makes you think different
because we're having this conversation
right now or it should meaning well I
don't even really have any playlists
because I don't even really have any
Series so then the goal is to trigger
okay great so then this next year when
you're building it out
the first R in our 7R system is start
with the end in mind reverse engineer if
I'm reverse engineering and I'm starting
with the end of mind and say Okay cool
so what would make this the perfect
Romanian Channel
what are the 10 basic questions is that
a series and you go okay well it's going
to take me a while to build that out but
I'm going to think what would my perfect
YouTube channel look like in six months
and if I work back from that which
videos would I upload what content would
I upload that I could then organize as
things evolve all right let's dive into
this and let's actually uh give it a
little click here on the newest video
and check it out here are some wishes
you can send to your Romanian friends
and family to your partner and even to
your Romanian boss on December 21st this
year hi Romania lover my name's Corina
really good definitely following best
practice you have a hook exactly what it
is then quickly introducing yourself
very warm good communicator on camera
a second language is my thing I love
that it would seem you're very using
very simple gear because it's probably
your phone way to punch you know just to
use the gear you have and getting that
that light in before the sun sets it
would seem that maybe the Sun is setting
but you still got some window light and
uh that's that's amazing so uh good
there you know practically and I don't
know if you worked you know got off work
still got the video in I want to send
you massive love and respect for doing
that
um but the more light the better that
your camera will look and it looks
actually totally fine but it looks it
breaks down a little bit cameras they
get uh the image quality just breaks
down when they don't have enough Light
smartphone cameras so just a thought and
and thinking about maybe tools that we
invest in as we get ready for a new year
is a simple softbox light kit man these
days you can a lot of time you can get
like one softbox light kit for forty
dollars a great one and and then it
gives you the ability because I know a
lot of us in the think media Community
are busy and you maybe do need to film
when it's dark and film in your basement
or set up some kind of a setup so
lighting is is uh just helpful
um
you can copy paste and send to your
Romanian people out there on New Year's
Eve make sure you keep watching until
the end because I prepared some wishes
you can send to your significant other
and I also prepared some wishes you can
send to your friends and family if you
want to just sound funny in Romanian
all right now I would say
if we break this down yes you gave a
good hook you introduced yourself you
did tell us to watch till the end
but there's a promise in your title
and then we don't actually get to the
New Year's greetings in Romanian until 0
48. so 48 seconds is how long I have to
wait until I actually get to the promise
of the title one of the things we just
talked about in our big five Trends to
pay attention to is the eight second
rule the eight second rule I actually
believe was discovered by UI ux
designers user interface user experience
designers on web pages
and it's based on the bounce rate of web
pages that if someone lands on a web
page they don't get what they want
they're confused there was actually a
study done that said if Amazon's website
lags just one second they can lose up to
1.8 billion dollars
which is crazy how impatient are you
that like oh it's not loading I'm not
even gonna buy this I'm going somewhere
else I'm going to bestbuy.com you know
you know forget you Amazon so what's the
principle the principle is and I've got
a practical tip here for you
is that we do want to cut to the chase
we do want to trim the fluff I actually
don't think the Practical tip is I don't
think this any of this is bad I think
your answer is Chapters I think you go
you go chapters and time codes and your
chapters become even just they could
just be number one number two number
three and when you scroll over a video
to redo your chapters because you've
done such great titles you could just go
zero I can see them like zero Forty Nine
the first New Year's greeting you know
two 120 the second New Year's greeting
and and then someone can literally the
fear is like oh is this gonna kill watch
time or hurt my channel like I don't
think it actually can what I actually
think it'll do is it increases it
because you what people who would have
normally bounced not just watch the
beginning they click to the first one
they get the point they might skip past
it but you still keep them longer but
even if you don't viewer satisfaction
goes higher I always like to think about
what's best for the viewer not what's
best for you and holding people hostage
usually doesn't make friends and so
ultimately just thinking about I think
time codes and chapters could be helpful
you know Dan I'm curious your thoughts
but one thing that does confuse me and
I'm assuming
that what I guess I'm assuming is that
your target audience is English speakers
because that's how you start that are
trying to learn Romanian and it's
learned Romanian with Karina which is
all fine but I always get a little
uncomfortable if we're trying to
have a Romanian audience it might be
obvious enough I don't think we are
because if if you are Romanian you
probably already know Romanian and so
what are your thoughts though based on
that or anything else happening here on
this channel
oh I'm getting an echo are you getting
that oh I think it's gone
um it's a bit it's a bit curious because
I kind of wonder what the ceiling is on
this content uh English speakers looking
to learn Romanian I'm sure that's a
thing I'm I'm just wondering maybe are
they are they kind of modeling this
channel off of another type of of
channel that teaches Romanian uh and
then what's that channel kind of doing
uh because the video we just watched
seemed very specific right it was you
know if you have family and friends and
you want to give them very specific
greetings for the new year here's some
suggestions so it's now now I'm
wondering it's not just people who want
to learn Romanians people who actually
have friends and relatives that speak
Romanian and they're trying to
communicate with them which I kind of
think is a different thing it kind of it
almost excludes Travelers you know
people who just want to visit the
country and when I think about it in
that sense but I don't I don't know if
it's that deep
um I did notice what they were doing
with shorts
and I thought uh we could probably speak
to this a little bit uh some of the
things they're doing in shorts I I don't
know if they're necessarily keeping the
shorts the typical shorts viewer in mind
so for example there is uh
win a free Romanian session with me
I think that would be a really good
Community tab
or uh as a long form video where you
kind of put that in there like by the
way I'm giving away a free session
I don't know if if I was scrolling on
shorts and this video kind of popped up
and it was you advertising this I'd be
kind of confused right because a lot of
people who find your shorts didn't ask
to see them YouTube shorts just kind of
tells you stuff it's like you're just
scrolling and it's like how about this
one how about this one and that's what
you always have to keep in mind when
making YouTube shorts a lot of people
don't get the chance to click on your
video first YouTube Just presents it so
I think a really great use of your
shorts and it did look like you were
doing this as well is giving really cool
things like I would say did you know
that saying blank in Romania sounds like
this or did you know that if someone
says this they're actually telling you
this I I think did you know videos that
take advantage of your expertise in this
language could really stand out on
shorts
that that that uh tip of being
thoughtful of who the shorts viewer is
of also the goal of reaching strangers
on shorts again people who don't know
you they don't have any context I like
that idea of did you know something
that's humorous maybe or something like
that are funny Romanian words that maybe
just are kind of shareable or the way
that phrase could be interpreted three
things or like if you say this this way
like one way to anger a Romanian if you
say this this way and then somebody like
they share it with their friends because
they're like yeah that's so true it's
funny she's saying this because that
would like you know uh make me upset
whatever and so I think some some good
thoughts there one last tip is in
addition to kind of cleaning up your
Channel
uh in a strategic week like this
doing some research about you could call
out your competition but just doing some
research about
what other channels in your industry are
doing
is powerful what kind of videos on their
channels are doing well and
also it reveals the upside potential of
your channel because you know this a
learn Romanian channel here is got 43
000 subscribers so it does show you
there's a lot of opportunity for growth
it would seem that this also is in my
opinion you know what you're doing but
it's verification of what you're doing
ever listened to it's English
um to an English audience that then also
eventually is teaching that and picture
this vocabulary section
what is this uh advertising a product of
some kind of a service here but learn
Romania in four hours so I'm assuming
want to know if your Romanian skills are
improving okay
photographia okay great so I mean this
is what this would teach me and this is
good for any of us to do in any Niche is
it's good to do some market research
because if you can discover other
channels doing what you're doing that
are having success and they have a
hundred thousand subscribers and the
practicality of you growing to 10 000
subscribers in the next years is is more
verified
alternatively if if you cannot find
anyone else being successful you're
either on to the most brilliant idea
or you actually might want to Pivot your
plan because there isn't in business
we'd call this The Tam the total
addressable market and in
entrepreneurship you'd call it
testing for Market viability before
starting a business so it's really just
kind of researching your industry and
then figuring out of course how you can
be different and things like that but
great Channel thank you so much uh for
uh submitting that if you are just
joining we are doing some Channel
reviews and some q a
um and
hit like and uh we are doing some
Channel reviews from our video raking
Academy I also did a Twitter post we're
going to be on here for
um about another half hour doing some
more and answering some q a uh Marianne
asks how do I get the vid IQ trending
tabs and stats icon on the channel bar I
had it but now it's gone so two things
you could do to get that is uh number
one
um
you want to make sure you and you
install vid IQ
Vision on Google Chrome that's what
allows you to have these cool Windows to
get your daily ideas or your keyword
inspector and all these cool vid IQ
tools
secondly you want to make sure it's
turned on and then you want to make sure
you're logged in and then thirdly you
want to make sure that you might refresh
and then fourthly sometimes when
trending and stats doesn't show up I've
noticed that it may not be either on
home but it'll show up on videos so uh
if you're and it'll still lead you to
the exact same place I think on think
media on home I don't have it but if I
click videos I've got my trending Tab
and then I can pop in and again this is
a powerful tool for
looking at your competitors or other
channels in your Niche to see what type
of videos are trending on their Channel
or also to see the real math behind
their Channel I mean this is what in
think media in the last month grew 30
000 subs and 4.5 million so whatever you
see up front you can't really aggregate
aggregate the data in your own mind it
gives you just some tools to say okay
well what is this channel doing and what
can I learn from it
um and so uh Gabriel says series could
be batch content absolutely you can
I've done many videos that way in fact
sometimes when preparing a video
one of the best things you realize is
this actually could be like four videos
you start preparing it and you're like
oh man I need to say this too and if I
say this as well and you're planning on
like Google Docs is where I plan and I'd
say this and then I go huh man I'm going
to be talking for 25 minutes maybe I
could break this into three parts
because part one is kind of it also
could have it gives you three
opportunities part one could kind of be
this title it ties into part two it ties
into part three and then you go all
right I'm gonna sit down and record all
three at once and anything like that is
creates leverage it it saves you time it
saves you energy because you're
compressing you don't just get one
upload out of it you get three uploads
it may take a little bit longer but you
have uh exponentially more impact from
your efforts and then uh Dan I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this so a lot of
people are seeing the opportunity right
now with
um
you know movie review channels even
gaming content they're essentially using
OPC other people's content and so free
lunch Carl's asking how do I actually
find video clips for TV shows and movies
and not get copyrighted is there a
website or an app and what's that you're
understanding about how are channels
allowed to do this
well uh certainly not legal advice I
don't claim to know the copyright system
or laws very well I just try and avoid
it at all costs but uh there is
something known as fair use and it's
more of a defense you don't want to find
yourself in a situation where you're in
court saying well fair use but uh if you
are using clips of this content the idea
is that it would be transformative right
so you were asking where to get them I
think what most people do is they
probably just screen record the clips
they're trying to show I I don't know
how else I like that's how I would do it
so if you're trying to do a movie review
of Glass Onion from Netflix you would
pull up Netflix you'd screen record the
clips you want and you'd put them in
your video you want to be transformative
you don't want to sit there and watch
Glass Onion with your audience you want
to start and stop a little bit you want
to say okay look at the scene right here
do you see what Daniel Craig is doing uh
that's actually a callback to the other
movie you know you can you can dive deep
on this stuff without getting into any
kind of trouble
supposedly uh if you're just careful to
be transformative you can't just take
stuff and just use it that's the idea
love it great point and one of the big
opportunities even if you're not a
YouTube automation Channel or a faceless
Channel I think the embracing of fair
use of course even the reaction you
could call it a niche but it doesn't
have to be a niche or a niche any
channel if it's on brand for you
reacting to a news clip reacting to
somebody on a video podcast saying
something creating conversation that is
a big opportunity 2023 to be thinking
about maybe trying a different content
format we actually narrowed down 16
different content formats answer
specific questions is one a react video
is one
um a a whiteboard video would be one and
one of the biggest exercises to stretch
and maybe break through a
plateau in your YouTube journey is
stretching yourself to do different
content formats if all you do is talking
head videos what if you did a narrated
video that was over all b-roll and so um
thinking about leaning into this fair
use opportunity is Big next up we have
my mentor Jane and
uh very clear branding very good Avatar
picture
um very clean Channel this would be your
new viewer the first impressions video
so let's check this out call me my
mentor Jane I'm on the Journey of life
not the life I think I have to settle
for or what other people think I deserve
I'm going for a good life where I'm
fulfilled Fully Alive free and filled
with joy so this is cool this is your
channel trailer it's cool because we're
catching your vision but here's a few
things we could break down and things we
could learn from not that I'm suggesting
this even needs a reshoot or a rewrite
but for anybody who wants to create a
channel trailer in 2023
um or just learn some best practices
about video here's a few thoughts first
I generally don't recommend starting
with intros
um because people want to get straight
to the point uh it's not terrible but
again this is taking time to get into it
okay Jane who is Jane
I meant to ordain cool
hard to kind of read this but it's clean
it's nice branding music that's the mood
hi it took 11 seconds to get to to the
actual content you might even throw that
at the end giving people the opportunity
to jump off if they want or go like wow
she has cool branding she has great
skills now I also think you are reading
from a teleprompter here it feels that
way and it's very natural I'm Jane
Aponte and I hope you will call me my
mentor Jane I'm on the Journey of life
so here's thing two I think that um one
of the things we talk all about is you
want to talk a lot more about you than I
and so what can happen is
um I know it's called YouTube because
you believe it's your tube and it is
your tube
and you could do whatever you want but
that doesn't mean it's going to be
successful we've learned that the
creators who are the most successful
they really put the viewer first now you
seem to be a mission-driven service
driven purpose-driven person so I know
that that's your goal you want to Mentor
you want to help people but before
people are interested in you they're
interested in themselves so it's like hi
I'm Sean
a better way to start your video and
even a channel trailer is to be
absolutely clear on what problem do you
solve for the viewer and to actually
start by agitating those pain points or
clarifying that that's that they're in
the right place
so I would typically open a video asking
questions is one way I do it and I'll be
like are you frustrated that your
YouTube channel is just not growing have
you been overwhelmed by trying to learn
all the different YouTube features how
and the technology well if so then this
channel is for you
if you want to hit your first 1000
subscribers and eventually get that
silver play button if you want to get
your channel monetized and learn the
best strategies for getting views
then you're gonna love the content that
we are posting here weekly for you
my name's Sean Cannell I've been a
mentor to creators you know like and so
you so you'd be moving this piece deeper
into the content and hooking the viewer
by making that Bond and that connection
and so a good audit you can do on
not just your content and the way you
open your videos but even on the about
page and the text that you write there
is the I versus you test and so it's how
often are you talking about you welcome
my name is Jane if you're curious about
how to follow Jesus and live a good life
then you're in the right place so that's
that's cool
um I think that could be powered up
um it's it's certainly a desire for
people that want to live out a Christian
Life a good life is good but I might
even go what I also like is when we say
answer specific questions in a 2023
world
but the world being so noisy it's nice
specific means
I want to learn the Bible specific means
I want to be I want to learn apologetic
so I can argue my faith specific it that
definitely means like how to follow
Jesus but that is more General
good life is super General
not necessarily a bad macro brand but
where the opportunity becomes this is
why we say the riches are in the niches
when you Niche down you want to become
the go-to channel for something specific
and actually
HootSuite and HubSpot and Adobe did all
these studies and we just aggregated all
of that content and Trends we'll link
that video up in the description if you
haven't watched it yet it's really like
our 2023 magnum opus and one of the
Trends they even re-emphasized is that
age-old
Niche point of the internet the riches
are in the niches that as there's more
content being more specific is even a
bigger deal right now and Zig Ziglar
said you don't want to be a Wandering
generality you want to be a meaningful
specific so I think it's a great Channel
I get the good life I'm sure the people
who have you have 463 subscribers things
are going incredible you are amazing you
have great energy your history so you're
really on the right track I'm just
trying to give you some power-ups you
know we're definitely in the the locker
room right now we're doing some coaching
I feel like you're winning the game but
it's halftime and we really want to make
sure we really win especially in this
next year you know so we're in the
locker room having hard conversations
and so you know you then go of course at
a very practical stuff here my workshop
style uh videos equip you to build the
right mindset the right skills so if you
were framing that in the beginning
tackle challenges this is now the
specific stuff that I'm loving
and it would be interesting to say okay
like are you trying to figure out how to
deal with the hardest issues in life uh
in a jesus-like way I maybe you're
overwhelmed with relationship conflict
maybe you're experiencing pain or
challenges like the more nuanced you get
into
um articulating for the viewers problem
the better in fact they say in business
that the person who can articulate the
problem the best wins like the the
customer that's trying the business that
creates a product that can explain it
the best the business that understands
the person's problem better than they do
will build the biggest connection so
again just a few things to power that up
and then I'll pass it to Dan here in a
second let's watch a little bit deeper
into this stuff Fully Alive free and
filled with joy as your Mentor through
these videos I'll equip and encourage
you with the mindset skills and habits
that lead to a good life now and this is
an interesting thing I'm I'm glad we're
doing this and this is it might be just
this opportunity of food for thought
um I would imagine you're incredibly uh
uh humble
and you seem very Meek spirited which is
amazing but another thing even in this
is
is your the Assumption of I'm already
your Mentor which I'm not saying you're
making that but as we get into it you're
like listen as you're as your mentor and
someone's just kidding here so they
might be like I don't know if you're my
mentor yet though I mean you know so I
think as far as a little bit of
positioning in regards to that as well
is here's how you do the same thing
because don't get me wrong like I
I when I communicate when I make videos
I know my intent of what I'm trying to
achieve because think about I'm a
YouTube Mentor but I want to make the
Assumption to just say listen I'm now
your YouTube Mentor that's going to be a
willful decision that the viewer makes
so what I might do is instead of going
so direct like that I would say I have
been mentoring hundreds of women
thousands of women over the last 10
years and I have developed you know a
unique process in helping them break
through challenges to break you through
that if if you would like to start
exploring that with me then definitely
subscribe does that make sense so so I'm
not suggesting that you're jumping to
that conclusion and I understand your
brain is my your brand is my mentor Jane
and I think that's all great I love it I
love the vibe but the same idea is kind
of taking this more
bridge building approach and considering
where people are at on the journey when
they're actually consuming and watching
this video let's land them they've
served me so well as a corporate
executive business owner wife sister and
so many other roles we play in life
I'm excited to share them with you great
each video provides information and
direction to help you with a challenge
problem or opportunity in your personal
life or career
but I go beyond that to provide
practical ways you can apply the
information to your situation very good
so love it and and this is still again
you're doing incredible here but I think
I hope that some in fact if you type yes
if if you found any of this conversation
uh helpful if you're able to think about
maybe your next videos or creating your
channel trailer those are just some kind
of like distinctions that I think could
take something good and make it great
um as far as your topics and thumbnails
and being on brand and having a Clear
Channel just seeing so many great things
here Jane and I I want you to feel
encouraged three uploads a week a month
rather and we are seeing some growth but
of course there's more opportunity here
so I'm curious Dan uh what are some of
your thoughts for Jane
so I'm looking at the channel trailer we
just watched and I'm looking at now the
this is the first I'm seeing of the
actual videos right the titles the
thumbnails we scroll down a little bit
I'm kind of curious to see what are some
of the subjects they've been covered
lately I had a break free uh from the
comparison trap okay if you're feeling
ignored overlooked
I think and you touched on this a little
bit I think I would like to see these
videos get a little more specific into
the problems that uh you know you're
you're obviously probably covering in
these videos I I think you've gone a bit
too General with the titles
and I don't know I would be speaking to
these just kind of they're so broad I
don't feel like they're targeting anyone
specifically
and that's going to be a challenge I
think for for this channel uh because I
I'm struggling to think of how I would
reframe these videos as well
that's a great point and and again we
say answer specific questions I I do
like I like um like the narcissist video
because that is a specific how to deal
with narcissists people have narcissists
in their life
I might even in into Dan's point
Don't Be Afraid though to go really deep
because you kind of also gave yourself
an out how to deal with narcissists is
very specific and you're like and
everybody else that's difficult so
rather like no like narcissist is deep
enough and so you could say you know how
to deal with narcissists when in in uh
in your research phase
this is also now we could dig even
deeper not even necessarily just a
narcissist but is it a narcissist
husband mother family member uh when
someone you love someone you love right
as a narcissist and so a a how to deal
with a narcissistic wife
is you know let's see here we have this
this video over here nine ways to deal
with the narcissistic wife 12 000 views
um how to improve a narcissistic
relationship 570
000 views and then it is it's worth
looking at okay once I'm locked in on
the topic I want to share researching
where some of the other people are
coming from and what are some of the
other angles not because of comparison
you're going to do your own style and
you're understanding who you're wanting
to reach
um but uh that that research could power
that up and rather just narcissists it
becomes incredibly personal if I'm
struggling with a family member like a
brother that I I've now kind of
discerned or I really feel like they
seem to be a narcissist they have all
the traits it's really a frustrating
relationship then that particular video
will leap off you YouTube when I'm in
that moment of pain and emotion and
looking for answers now you have a video
that doesn't just come out but what are
we after we're after a video that serves
anybody that subscribed to you that
might have that challenge but it
potentially can serve YouTube and
viewers on the internet for weeks months
and years to come if it ranks if it pops
off and so as you hit those specific
topics that becomes a big opportunity to
uh
to really have a a video crush and I
would I would agree and I want everyone
to hear this as well we just can't hit
the answer specific part hard enough
like
When God says no but you really want it
two powerful lessons
this is not necessary I think people can
relate to that people that are you know
active in a prayer life but I like to
hit really concrete stuff that
um that people are are dealing with it
could be
that's like okay that's kind of it's not
ethereal but concrete and that's where
Dan was going as well so it could be
like how to deal with divorce how to
um begin understanding or studying the
Bible
um you know apology fail for reasons it
falls flat and how to fix it it's kind
of a okay
is that somebody that apologized it's
sort of confusing if you confuse you
lose is this about
how to
apologize to someone who hurts you
and when we take something like this in
a 2023 world
I think that titling I think Dan would
agree that's why vid IQ has created such
great tools it's not necessary look at
this though over text deeply deeply
through text marriage and you start
seeing that these are very specific
desires that people have this is your
expertise as Jane the the mentor and you
start to dig deep into some of these but
you could take something that's basic
from like the YouTube search bar here
and then you could take it over to AI
title recommendations and maybe even see
some more meat on the bones five simple
steps for apologizing to someone you've
hurt
if that's a video that inspires you or
that was the direction you were going
with the video this title is like 10 out
of 10. I mean that's the point of the
tool it's just it's like man that slap
simple's good how to apologize exactly
what the viewer would be looking for how
do I I hit the refresh button here so
five easy steps on how to apologize to
someone who hurts you and then of course
you're like well I don't have five steps
well yeah well then make it a three I
mean that's that's you know here's the
three simple steps so it's kind of just
putting it into a context
um and and gives you different angles
you could take here so that's the uh
that's used the AI title recommendation
tool but I think one of the places you
can start is by really thinking about
what video do you want to make next
maybe use the YouTube search bar or some
of it iq's keyword research tools
get kind of the concept down even study
out a little a few of the other videos
on YouTube in the topic think about your
unique angle on it and and doing all
this this is why Janie I know you're a
video record Academy member
this is why when you start mastering the
first two r's in our 7R system reverse
engineer who's this video for even when
even though you know your channel now
but who is this video for and to
understand them you know what are they
feeling what are the problems and
Ambitions second research and and
research could involve what other videos
are on YouTube
keyword research researching
tidal angles because you're galvanizing
the concept before you press record
research researching the information
you're going to share from your past
journals from current new content from
recent articles you've read from a Bible
study that you're going through and
you're you're Gathering all of these
resources putting that together and also
formulating your your script or your
outline and now the unity of all the
above makes the record phase a whole
other level the release phase a whole
nother level the rocket and rank you
know and the whole thing works together
ultimately as a system
um if you've been getting value out of
this uh training today we hope that
Beyond these Channel reviews you're
getting a lot of tactics
um definitely watch the replay because
we've been sharing a lot of stuff and
today's video is also brought to you by
vid IQ
if you want to try a 30-day trial of vid
iq's paid plan it's just a dollar
vidiq.com Dan uh is a part of uh vid IQ
and Dan are you able to show us this um
this new tool that is coming out tell us
a little bit about this cool new feature
that you guys have yeah uh you can pull
up my screen if you want it's uh our new
AI coach uh this is an early preview of
the AI coach and just a fun fact before
we dive into it if you have a vid IQ
account period end of story you can try
this out while it is an early preview so
all you need is a vidiq account you can
go to app.vidiq.com chat and you can try
it out so think chat GPT but if it were
trained as a YouTube coach and so what I
did earlier Sean this is I'm sorry
that's why I got distracted earlier I
was trying to think of a prompt for when
we got to this point that would be fun
and I wouldn't have to type it live and
so the prompt I'm giving it is hello I
have a pet Channel where myself and my
27 cats get into all kinds of hijinks
but I'm out of my I'm out of ideas for
new videos could you help me come up
with five new video ideas that I can do
with my 27 cats
so you click that it's going to take a
second to think and hopefully we will
get five video ideas sure I'd love to
have you come up with some new creative
ideas
just a bit I can uh no judgment from the
AI bot by the way which I appreciate
um
so one cat obstacle course create an
obstacle course for your cats to
complete and time them to see who can
come first cat stunts Challenger cats to
do funny stunts like jumping over a toy
mouse cat bathing document the process
of bathing 27 cats and their reactions
uh you can do a cat food taste test you
could do cat paw casting make a cast of
your cat's paws and create unique
artwork with prints
so yes these can get very specific
um so if you have 27 cats and you don't
want to be judged for that and you need
some video ideas I'd highly recommend
this tool it can do all sorts of fun
things
amazing so I love it because of course
uh vid IQ you guys just continue to
innovate it is not a static uh software
and Tool solution but new tools for the
new needs of a new year and so yeah if
you want to try out vid IQ check out
vidiq.com forward slash think there is a
link in the Facebook text and there's
also
um one in the YouTube description and
show notes and uh let's check out
another question here would you
recommend a specific trailer promotion
video in 2023 or just use a trailer to
feature your most popular video and
update that regularly Dan what's your
thoughts
uh I was actually gonna bring this up I
didn't want to start a controversy in
the last uh Channel we were looking at
but I was going to bring this up I was
going to ask you too uh I personally am
an advocate for taking your best work
and making that the channel Trailer part
of that set of laziness I'm already
working really hard on all the videos
I'm making do I have to also sit down
and make a very direct to camera video
about what my channel is about or can I
just kind of show you with what I think
my best video is and I've noticed that
those videos tend to you know I think
convert one thing that we've found is
that the Subscribe button on the front
page of your YouTube channel the one
with your channel banner and all that
that's the one people click the most and
I think it's because people before they
make that commitment to you I'm going to
be a subscriber of yours they're trying
to learn everything they can about you
so having a good Channel Banner having a
strong trailer that's a good
demonstration of what your channel is
about and then having a nice layout for
your Channel having the proper playlists
there your shorts if they're there all
of that is selling points for your
channel so my personal preference is to
use your your best video but like the
video we saw from Jane was also really
good there was a lot of thought that
went into I'm just going to tell people
in one and a half minutes what this is
and there was a lot to that I think that
is not invalid at the end of the day it
might come down to personal preference
I'd be curious to hear your thoughts on
that Sean
so after giving her all of those details
what is interesting is I do agree with
you and I and I think that the
distinctions for Jane are an any video
could be valuable we do not have a
channel trailer so I'm right with you
like I I'm not out here advocating I
would want to practice what we preach
and what we do is we do select we go to
our our real-time views or the last 90
days on our Channel and look at the
videos that are most likely to convert
subscribers or most likely to provide
viewer satisfaction and then the other
lens I use is exactly what she said it's
like
um what would be a good first impression
what would also be maybe more of a good
starting point as opposed to deeper in
the journey with our Channel and we
recently updated what the video on fake
media that new subscribers see I also
just changed over think media podcast
Channel yesterday and so
um the the two options are not just the
channel trailer but also returning
viewers which might be something what's
a good follow-up video for them to see
and so I would agree with you the one
distinction I would say to answer
directly I do not think it's gonna save
you time I do not think you need to do
it the one distinction I would say is I
think creating a a story based
value-based
first impression video that also could
stand on its own with the intent of it
being a channel trailer
is a good idea to be clear to be more
specific in our case with think media
and
Based on data and one of our big five
trends
is vocalize your values and it's not our
opinion other brands there's people want
to follow brands that stand for
something
so if you're actually looking to make a
bond and not just get a view
if you're actually looking to go beyond
views vocalize your values what does
that mean it would just kind of mean
most videos you're not going to
necessarily share the mission and the
vision of your channel but if you could
find a way to add value in a video
introduce the characters that's a unique
thing for us we have multiple characters
Nolan Omar interviews what the channel
is all about add value in the video and
also vocalize our values it's actually
kind of an interesting thing because I
recently did that in that Trends video
and I got like one or two comments that
actually got a little upset not even
upset but they're like oh you shared
your your values and your faith and
we're not going to watch we're out of
here haha gotcha you're it turns out
vocalizing your values is not true
and I was like okay
well let me read the rest of the
comments I have never gotten more
comments on a video that said wow I
really didn't know where you stand and
now I have a greater bond with you than
ever before see what people are afraid
is the two people that are that are
gonna be triggered by your values but
what you don't understand is you're not
just getting views when you vocalize
your values you might have 10 50 100
that now are ride or die with you for
life
somebody who's more on the surface of
even even understanding social media
marketing and business
doesn't understand that this is about
raving fans classic Business book super
fans new social media Pat Flynn Business
book and it's a lot more about I think
especially in a noisy World those that I
win are not just going to get shallow
shallow views and passive viewers
they're going to create greater depth So
to that end I guess what I would be
saying Dan is that
by the way we have our work cut out for
us so we're actually kind of I'm kind of
we're always thinking about we're
probably overthinking it we're thinking
about it like okay so Nolan and Omar and
Sean get together we maybe show some of
the other think media team like what do
we and we uh how do we like add value
and kind of tell our story and do make
it somewhat narrative driven and also
then kind of share where we stand with a
a video that we would upload anyways but
then would essentially become our our
Channel trailer so that and and then I
guess the final thing is that as the
channel evolves we realize that people
don't even really know what think media
does and people don't just want to hear
a story about you so how do we weave
that into an entertaining but like the
fact that we have a tech Channel and a
podcast Channel and our video record
Academy course that also has all
happened in the evolution of doing this
now for seven years of me doing it for
like 10 years previous to that so so it
depends on where you are in the journey
and we just realize okay how can we tell
our story not in a way that people don't
even really actually care unless you
make them the hero of the story frame it
around what value you'll get from the
channel so that might be a more
sophisticated way of thinking about
putting something out there Dan I'm
curious about your thoughts on some of
that
I I think building that kind of bond
with an audience can definitely be very
very powerful uh and it really just
depends on yeah what your goals are you
know uh you you might find that if you
do certain things it can alienate some
of your audience that they won't they
might not love that if you're not
comfortable doing that there's no rule
book there you can you can choose to
kind of play it straight
um but if you want to put more of
yourself out there I've definitely seen
that like benefit people as well
um I just I I don't know if there's
necessarily like a right or wrong way uh
just on that one topic yeah and when I
say vocalize your values too not all
values are actually going to be as pull
like some it might your value could just
be freedom in the crater economy your
value could be right we want to plant
trees and so in addition to entertaining
like and I think it's a powerful thing
to just think about though that people
are looking for more depth and more
connection and so I'm excited to talk
about that more we got one more channel
to review avidian Smith and uh
machine tips and hacks
machine with an S is a machine in
particular so I've been making beats
ranging for video game samples Soul
sampling dubstep chill step and sampling
Lo-Fi and boom bap amazing
FL Studio Native Instruments great on
this channel you can expect to see I
love this list and I love the Emojis
because it just I actually scan past in
a way this block of text and it's like
just make it simple you can expect beats
tutorials YouTube tips for music
producers and so it's great really clear
um and uh let's dive into some of the
the videos here this is another cool new
YouTube feature to notice is that when
you
are
using playlists
intelligently
he has made a playlist called Native
Instruments
and machine tips and tricks and that
Aggregates this series all into one
playlist well now YouTube is making that
a clickable feature right next to the
Views the upload time and So for anybody
that maybe wants to go really deep in
that and I guess I'm assuming that
machine spelled with an S is is either a
brand for you or that's actually what
like what a product name is I think it's
a product I think it's software the
machine plus okay I got it great and
then um
cool to see that you're doing uh live
streaming or you have one scheduled or
is this a or is that a Premiere
scheduled does it notify me
um
premieres okay so you're using premieres
there cool
um and so
what are your thoughts Dan
yeah this is a really strong for
especially for a music channel this can
be a very tough spot on YouTube and uh
this is I'm seeing some really cool
stuff a lot of value driven content it's
uh I said software earlier it looks like
the machine might be Hardware actually
and that's that's really cool because
there's a lot of different devices and a
lot of different things that musicians
could probably benefit from it's kind of
like our space with cameras and
different Tech that we use for making
videos you're going to find that
musicians need certain you know reviews
of of products they're looking for so
this is this is excellent because you
are uh you know you're just getting into
the space where there's obviously a
market for it and I I think this is a
pretty good well-rounded Music Channel
um yeah this is this is a display of
expertise and uh I think this is going
to help them go really really far
one of the things just that I've learned
is
the most practical
path to success on YouTube
is
making utility-based videos be it's and
in comparison to what in comparison
potentially to
entertainment and entertainment could be
music because that's predicated on
people's like or dislike of the music
um it also could be how saturated
something is
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um
it would seem I think the other piece
though is
and so tutorial based videos the reason
I say that is if I'm you some of the
initial videos I'm making and probably
the first 100 and then I'd probably
follow up with the next 900 videos
would be videos like machine MK3
tutorial for beginners and nuancing may
be more down on that but when I look at
134 122 000 and 11 000
as a new channel the practicality of you
getting 1200 views around
you know 2023 Because by the way these
people have not had the time no one's
had the time yet to do a 2023 video so
like update it for 2023 maybe because a
firmware update has come out and jumping
on that utility-based tutorial based
content and then you've got a zillion
other distinctions so you know how to
sample how to make beats versus the plus
if you got both how to integrate Ableton
in it and so these again go back to
really answer specific questions teach
specific skills lots of affiliate
opportunities and all of the above but
the final thing I'll say is it's kind of
a strategic question
um
one of the challenges on YouTube is
asking yourself why are people
subscribing
and so
if people are subscribing because of
this beat and and why are they listening
to this why are they watching to this
are you selling this
is it just
for them to listen to so they're just
listening to this to enjoy it this is
maybe a part of a playlist of Lo-Fi
chill music that they're listening to
while studying
well
if that's bringing in subscribers then
my argument would be
99 of them aren't probably wanting to
make Lo-Fi music they're wanting to
listen to Lo-Fi music
in a business world you could say this
is the difference between B to B and B
to C B to B would be I want to start a
beat making business even if it's just a
hobby b2c is I don't want to start a
beat making business I want to listen to
Beats
You're Building both on the same channel
I think that's okay but it it it you
play that out to it's extreme it can
kind of confuse the algorithm because if
you put a lot of Lo-Fi playlists out and
different things then you're just not
going to get clicks on the tutorial
based videos as much so if you really
Niche down in terms of you've got the
Beats themselves versus the tutorials
I don't know if you should ever really
combine if possibly you should avoid
combining B to B and B to C it's two
different channels typically and I'm
also not necessarily YouTube tips for
music producers
beats and we've seen it played out with
lots of Beats only channels and then the
tutorials the tips and the motivation
for producers
these are that's this is like a channel
and the Beats is like a channel so just
a thought I think you could you'll still
be fine if you keep going the same
direction but then alternatively if you
go heavy on the tutorials
that's maybe even I would lean heavier
on the tutorials I think there's more
monetization opportunities there there's
uh there's
it's more practical to kind of grow you
also don't even know to need to grow
that large to have a significant impact
and even significant income what's cool
about the beets is that these
subscribers this is showing off that you
know what you're doing it is showing off
that you know it's proving and being a
player coach and actually doing the
thing but that would be a that'd be a
thought that I have in terms of I think
you have unlimited Opportunity by by
doing these types of videos on how to
hack and chat chop samples
and uh and being just thoughtful about
your 2023 strategy about who is your
channel for what have they subscribed
for and I know we all break these rules
listen I know we break the rule at think
media because if we do a final cut
series for example anybody who doesn't
use Final Cut Pro won't click on that
nor would they want to watch it so I
know that at some point there is the
rule and you may break it and you may
break it thoughtfully but the goal is to
never upload a video your subscribers
didn't subscribe for
so understanding why are people
subscribing what videos are attracting
subscribers are they truly attracting
the subscribers I want and am I having
two am I really having two audiences on
one channel that are getting confused I
think being thoughtful of that can be
really helpful
Dan let's land a plane with uh a couple
questions here hit like if you got value
today yeah we added hour blocks but
we're at an hour and 36 minutes if
you've been getting value uh in fact let
me know what has been your greatest aha
moment we are action takers here at the
think media podcast share aha moment in
the comments of what is something you
you need to do next what is something
you need to work on in your channel is
it winter cleaning on your channel if
you're in Australia is it summer
cleaning on your channel
um is it time to uh to work on your next
video or what is something what did you
like best that stood out that um you're
going to implement
um next when it comes to uh your YouTube
channel and uh we're gonna pull up one
or two more questions here uh Heather
said the eight seconds get to the value
quick
start using the pin comment simple
little details and once you develop that
habit thanks for sharing that Shania
um is uh simple little details
eventually they become like like just
tying your shoes like you just get used
to it you know it's like put the Hat on
put on the weird space sweatshirt tie my
shoes turn on my lights I'm ready for
the live stream
um Marianne yes summer cleaning of my
channel is it is it because is it is
you're in the UK right is it summer in
the UK because it's winter here in
Seattle uh let me know uh let's see
Circle says for me personally got to get
that second long form posted in the
trailer posted amazing time to spruce up
the channel Tiffany cheers sending you
holiday greetings and and New Year's
greetings Australia yes
I wish I was there in the sun on the
beach
not in the rain in the Northwest in
overcast weather I need to go take my
vitamin D supplements because my mood is
crashing faster
than FTX all right uh Australia in the
place here all right let's answer a
couple more questions as we land the
plane today
um okay
uh all right Twitter is looking for a
video to be done on their platform what
contents would work on that platform
damn thoughts on Twitter stepping into
the video game
yeah this is interesting I it's uh it's
funny because months before the big
acquisition I was noticing a push on on
video as well and I was finding myself
clicking on those videos and similar to
YouTube shorts and Tick Tock I think
um and I'll just speak from like a
personal experience I like really quick
bite-sized pieces of content that are
just going to entertain me like if I'm
on Twitter it's likely I'm trying to get
a quick fix of something whether it's
just to laugh or maybe I'm trying to get
updated on some news so it's kind of
like the same as YouTube advice right be
thinking about the audience that you're
trying to cater to on Twitter be
thinking about the broader audience on
Twitter and why they might be using the
app at that time and if you tend to
cover news or anything like that maybe
it's making a video that's covering a
trending topic and on Twitter that's
home of trending topics right there's
the whole section for it if you have
thoughts or opinions on something that's
currently trending get your phone out
get a video done as fast as you can and
get it posted
um what I don't know will work or not
because I I don't know much about this
but could you make like a searchable
video that gives General tips and tricks
like diy things like that on Twitter I
don't know I don't know if they really
have a search algorithm that would cater
itself to that so I would really focus
on like the here and now if it was me
and start testing there but I say this
is someone who's a Layman I've not tried
to post videos on Twitter before so I
would love to know from other people out
there who have tried this what's worked
and what hasn't
that'll be interesting to watch and see
how Twitter evolves it anything Elon
does is um for sure entertaining
um Facebook user says and I open up the
other screen so I see you Dustin over in
our group by the way if you go to
yeah
streamyard.com forward slash Facebook
you can approve it so that we can see
your avatar over here but I love this
question so when sharing your values
should I also share about being a
veteran or is that something that pushes
people away
um if it's relevant for the channel I
think you absolutely should one thank
you for your service
um
to
I want to encourage you to not be afraid
of pushing people away three
we're not talking about forcing your
values
into content just for the sake of doing
it
um you know as a Christian for example
one of the things that's funny is I do
think that businesses that are like
overly Christian they're like I'm a
Christian plumber
I'm like I don't even know that's
possible what do you what do you mean
like you're just a plumber
now you might have values and ethics but
if you go overboard so like we don't do
like Christian camera reviews you know
what I mean so it's like you wouldn't
need to do like veteran camera reviews
but I think what we're talking about
here is
the reason this is so powerful is uh you
know Simon selected the talk start with
why people it's not what you do or how
you do it but why you do it that really
builds movements and builds bonds
so what you do well every everyone's got
a tech Channel how you do it well MKBHD
does it in 4k with a red camera while
Sean does it with my weird style and I
do stream yard web class webinars with
decks when I teach YouTube tips like
your how it can be different your music
choice your style the way you talk your
Vibe so what is usually pretty common of
a level that's a distinction though how
that's also like your unique flavor you
your Unique Style some different you
know
um the way you get it there's different
YouTube channels that maybe do the same
what in a different way but why you do
it is really what
bonds people to you and people like to
follow people with shared beliefs and
people like to follow people with shared
values so again we are
like you think about think media it's a
wide open Channel with all kinds of a
diverse following but the people who
follow us at the deepest levels
typically come pretty close to a values
alignment and when your values I would
imagine as a veteran is somebody who
loves your country who loves freedom of
somebody who has high ethics High
character of somebody that
um cares about family and cares about uh
fighting for people's rights I think
that weaving that stuff into your
content just makes it all the more
powerful furthermore if you being a
veteran offended somebody good riddance
please unsubscribe I think having the
boldness to just realize that there
should be a level of fearlessness and
courage when you truly know who you are
and you truly know where you stand and
you also realize how big the world is
you should be afraid of people
unfollowing unsubscribing even insulting
you or putting you down for your values
and beliefs first of all anyone who
would insult someone for their values
and beliefs you really don't want them
subscribed anyways so I actually think
raising your standard articulating your
values and being Bolder about what you
believe if that polarizes people away
free from you good and on the flip side
I don't think it's about being weird or
trying to be overly offensive it's when
these things would come up naturally in
conversation and many videos they
probably wouldn't although you might tie
it in and and and and that's that's I
think the key you're still putting the
viewer first and thinking about what is
actually going to add value to the
viewer there is no reason for me to do a
Christian camera review you know what I
mean just doesn't make sense I want to
do the best camera review ever the best
you know whatever and then I might
invite somebody at the end of the video
to be like I also have a podcast
where you share YouTube tips and then on
the podcast I'm only going to share
YouTube tips but then I might go into an
episode where we talk about our mission
and vision and there's different
contexts for different rooms where
different things come up and so I hope
that helps Dustin in terms of just being
thoughtful of uh what room are you in
what's going to add value to the viewers
but again thank you for your service and
if anybody's offended by you serving and
fighting for your country
peace we never wanted you here anyways
for real and so uh the gaming mom this
one's for Dan
any idea why shorts have taken directly
from my content are slow on views and
Dan I've heard a lot of people ask this
to be clear as I tee this up you can
look at like an old video use the
feature on your phone pull content out
of a horizontal landscape video turn it
into a YouTube short and a couple
complaints I've seen is actually that
even the resolution can be kind of janky
it also crops so that can be kind of
weird but Dan what's been your
experience here
yeah I've tried that a couple times and
I'll tell you what I struggle with the
most using that particular feature it's
context it's really really hard to take
a live stream for example find a clip in
there that has all the context a brand
new viewer would need without having to
watch the live stream and on a deeper
level I've also noticed that if I take
clips from the live stream and let's say
I Stitch I I do it myself right I set up
what's called a replay buffer if you use
OBS it's very easy to do and every time
something funny happens in my gaming
stream I hit the button and it saves a
clip of my hard drive where I can go
back and edit that into a video so now I
have control YouTube's not compressing
my video I have a nice clean clip to
play with so I get to stitch in all the
context I want my shorts and even that
I've noticed doesn't do nearly as well
in shorts then if I sit down and make a
video intentionally for YouTube shorts
and nothing else it wasn't a live stream
before it wasn't a long form video I
made it for them because now I have all
the control I have from start to finish
the entire context of what they're gonna
watch in my brain and so it's going to
come out of my head and onto a vertical
video that is 20 to 30 seconds long and
I always find those videos doing better
and it's because I'm able to plan them
out so much easier so barring that let's
say you're just you're like but I want
to take clips for my long form videos I
want to take clips from my live streams
add to them go in afterwards get in
front of that clip and say I was playing
blank and you'll never believe what
happened and then let the clip roll so
that way if I'm scrolling through shorts
and I find your video that I did not ask
to watch because YouTube thought I might
like it
and I find that video I'm being told
immediately this was during something
else I was not there for something but
you're telling me hey I know you weren't
here for this but check this out you'll
never believe what happened in this game
look at this amazing kill that I got
look at this amazing catch I got in this
fishing game like that's that's what
people need I think is that context
brilliant answer that's not my favorite
feature my favorite way to do it is is
like Start From First principles and
create the content originally agreeing
with Dan there uh Dan we got a question
about vid IQ and by the way friends uh
today's video is brought to you by vid
IQ right now you can actually get a
30-day trial of one of vid iq's paid
plans for just a dollar at vidiq.com
forward slash think but uh one of our
VRA fam asked
um
how can we upgrade if you try to upgrade
the site won't let me I get an error on
a paid plan and so there's different
plans correct there's uh your Boost plan
your max plan your Pro Plan any tips on
this
um
you shouldn't be having that issue
um if the upgrade button is not working
that sounds like a customer support
issue unfortunately so support vidiq.com
they should get back to you very quickly
it is the holidays so maybe response
times are a tad slow I don't know how
the rest how the team is right now in
terms of vacations and stuff but
um they will get back to you that should
not be happening and I apologize for
that um because yeah there's no reason I
could think of that that would be
happening yeah and if you are logged
into the web
app
app.vidiq.com I don't know if you're
doing it that way you're you're properly
logged in I'm logged in as our think
media channel right here we also have
Nolan's Channel and think uh uh
marketing think media podcast now our
video influences channel so if you're
logged in
um and you go to app.vidiq.com
com forward slash plans go to upgrade
should work but yeah definitely reach
out to support if you need help uh with
that well Dan I want to thank you so
much for being a part of the stream
today really appreciate you and grateful
for you
um happy New Year merry Christmas and
any final word for our community yeah
happy New Year Merry Christmas uh it's
it's been awesome I I think this has
been a really crazy year on YouTube in a
good way YouTube has is I said this
yesterday it's literally unrecognizable
because they physically did change the
website uh but even things they've added
to YouTube in just this past year make
me so excited for what comes next in
2023 because they kicked off the year
with a video like hey there's a lot of
changes coming in 2022 and they stuck to
it and month after month we were getting
update after update and so as someone
who loves live streaming if someone was
making shorts and there's someone who
was making videos uh they're they're
hitting it on they're firing all
cylinders and they're hitting us from
all directions with different types of
content Community tab for everybody now
like whatever kind of content you want
to make you can make it all here and
it's only going to get better so I'm
just really excited about the future
Dan appreciate you and agree it's been a
wild year and super excited for 2023 on
YouTube we are all the data is pointing
to this next decade it's going to be the
best decade on YouTube so much growth
there's so much opportunity and that's
the point of this channel is to help you
win and help you grow on YouTube we're
on a mission to help 10 000
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living doing what they love while making
a difference in the world with YouTube
and online video and I want to encourage
you if you have not seen oh by the way
uh video ranking Academy I know we were
streaming this into the group as well
every month we do this in the group
there so go to the events Tab and look
at um
the next one to make sure that's
scheduled and you have set a reminder so
you could be a part of that where we do
Channel reviews and video reviews we do
it at least once a month in the group
there and so I look forward to seeing if
you're in our video ranking Academy to
see you inside uh if you are not
subscribed to the think media podcast
definitely subscribe a new episode
coming out tomorrow that you're not
going to want to miss of course it's on
all the audio platforms as well as uh
video but we have I recently did the
five big trends to know about on YouTube
in 2023 it's a little bit more concrete
than predictions it um is really
researched I spent about 40 hours of
research Gathering all this information
for different experts as well as our
data at think media so click or tap the
screen to watch that video next my name
is Sean Cannell rhymes with YouTube
channel appreciate you so much Happy New
Year and we will talk soon